the Joe Rogan experience we're just
we're instead what we see is just very
extreme talking points first of all very
extreme interpretations of the actual
problem and therefore leading to very
extreme solutions to that problem all
right if you say the world's ending in
12 years and why not have a green new
deal right like it so it's you're
operating off of a premise that is
highly extreme and it's just it's not
it's not healthy political discourse
it's meant to animate people it's meant
to get people upset and to have a
villain it it always comes back to the
villain and the oppressor and oppressed
it always comes back to this everything
everything somebody like Bernie Sanders
says can be traced to this specific
ideology where one person is to blame or
one institution is to blame and I think
that's extremely unhealthy way to look
at things and also intellectually
dishonest I don't know the parameters of
a green new deal the new Green Deal or
whatever the [ __ ] it is but you hear it
all the time what and what is the idea
behind this at its core a complete shift
to wind and solar at its core so a an
idea that if you do that you will you
will have zero emissions in the next 10
years but it's an obsession with wind
and solar which i think is interesting
it bans nuclear remember when the
talking points came out from the green
new deal didn't like nuclear so that's
how you know it's not an actual
environmental plan or at least
associated with carbon emissions and
then climate change because why would
you ban the the one reliable piece of
energy that we have that has zero
emissions which is nuclear so you know
it's not about that it also includes
free health care for everybody it
includes free college so it's like it's
like every socialist plan wrapped into
one and then they call it an
environmental plan and and ban fossil
fuels and things like that so that's a
fundamentally what it is it's a wish
list of things like that
well nuclear has this inherent fear of
things going wrong Chernobyl yeah you
know there is a shame when that costo we
also put nuclear reactors on like
submarines and put a bunch of people on
them and go down to depths and put
torpedoes and stuff on them so I mean
it's sure you know well mains very safe
amount of nuclear energy that's been
used in this country versus the amount
of times we've had nuclear disasters and
there's also the problem with these old
systems that weren't like Fukushima
were implemented in the 1960s and 1970s
they just they're not as good yeah we
just it's true but we do have the
technology to make them good and I think
we should look at ways to research more
the miniaturized modular nuclear devices
that are that are being looked at a
nuclear car maybe we can get you home I
don't have them yet imagine you should
have a nuclear card you have a nuclear
car about a nuclear everyone's name
thrower crazy so the new green deals
just wind and solar it concentrates on
just windmills yes or and then the idea
is to replace the grid with some sort of
mean California it seems like it could
be possible like you could just put
solar panels on everybody's roof in
California you'd probably reduce the
amount of electricity that we need from
the grid radically yeah it gets
complicated because you don't have Sun
at night and and so this is the
complication of wind and solar in
general is that the you you need battery
backup to really make this work and that
technology just isn't there the
theoretical it's just not there I mean
you don't you don't off the grid with
solar power right but you to make this a
to do that but when they don't like you
say when there is no Sun the plants
shift whether you know natural gas or
coal or something here this is a perfect
example like here this is a goofy place
to live because it doesn't rain we have
Sun every day but not at night
and so this but 1200 needs Sun is enough
well only if you have batteries only if
you have the batteries to store it and
so yeah in theory if you live we do and
we don't right now like for if you
actually if you want a certain if you
want to shift the entire energy grid to
that we do not have this the the massive
amounts of there's some good data on
this I don't have it off the top of my
head its massive it is a massive amount
of batteries and farms to actually hold
that there's an energy density problem
with wind and solar it's it's a physics
problem so the science can only go so
far and even the theoretical limit to
how much a battery can hold probably
which we're not even we haven't
discovered yet but it's a theoretical
like capacity of a battery it would
still make it very difficult to actually
do this and so it's it's just real not
realistic also also there's other
consequences to wind and solar like
massive you know solar term or wind
turbines okay those are some people
don't like those things
massive amounts of space needed for for
for solar and also where you're gonna
get that that the the special materials
needed for solar panels like there's
there's other consequences to this and
it's it's it's not self-evident that's
the only possible way to do it it's not
it's nothing we should shun it okay that
nobody's saying that it should we
advocate for a long above approach if
our goal is less carbon emissions than
we need to be focusing on 100% of carbon
emissions meaning the world's carbon
emissions a green New Deal focuses on 15
percent of carbon emissions basically
says let's kneecap the United States
economy will will destroy fossil fuels
will have a utopian society full of wind
and solar even though the batteries
don't exist to make that work but hey
we'll make it work so then then that
then that solves 15% of the problem and
has almost no effect on on the actual
climate so when I say a hundred percent
of the problem what I'm saying is
technological innovation whether that's
nuclear or carbon capture if the goal is
less carbon then let's actually focus on
carbon capture hmm so I just dropped a
bill Senator Cornyn did on the on the
Senate side called leading act and it
basically it repurposes grant funds in
the Department of Energy to focus on
carbon capture for natural gas plants so
we have natural gas plants in Texas that
are zero emissions they take in natural
gas they operate the the facility they
create electricity and then they
recapture that carbon and they power the
facility with it zero emissions so four
goal is zero emissions let's do it works
and also by the way that plant can keep
going no matter what does that say what
time of day it I didn't know that that
existed that's amazing called net power
we talked about something on the podcast
before just as a joke I was saying why
don't they just make a giant building
but make an air filter like a huge
building the size of an air filter but a
carbon capture yeah shoot huge air
filter the size of a building but
apparently they're doing that
apparently China is in the process of
building things like that
I've heard of some things in trying to
think yet because they have an air
pollution problem yeah that's different
from carbon okay so like because carbon
dioxide you're breathing it right now
you're not polluting it right
necessarily they've got a different
problem and they're just a mess and so I
that might be what they're doing but the
cut on the carbon capture side it's
definitely happening that's all the oil
company is actually doing it because
there's actually an interest in the oil
and gas industry to reduce carbon
emissions
there's a huge interest I mean they they
realize where the conversation is going
and we should encourage that you know so
there's pretty impressive big projects
going on by a lot of these by a lot of
these folks so your take is that what
the green new deal is that means if I
can encapsulate it your with the green
new deal is basically more of an
emotional plea to people that are
worried about the future and that see
wind and solar as being free and clean
alternatives
it's a dogmatic approach to those it's
not based and makes people feel good
it's a it's a feel-good thing and it
really shouldn't make them feel good we
could just because of all of consequence
as I said about wind and solar it's not
these aren't necessarily clean by
themselves it also involves Conflict
Minerals right that you need for these
no that's what I was getting at - yeah
like what do you what do you mind these
things it's not it's not the United
States it's not the United States where
we have child labor laws good intentions
often lead to bad things so look at the
ethanol issue when we decided that we
wanted ethanol in our gasoline well I
think it was I want to say it's
Indonesia or Malaysia but they cleared
tons and tons of forests - to make room
so that they could so that they could
produce the ethanol oil
all right carbon emissions they're
increase rapidly because of that you
know all because of our good intentions
and like these incentives in these
second third order effects they matter
and we have to think about them when
we're we're talking about policy and if
our goal again is if our goal is less
emissions then let's let's be thoughtful
about how we approach that let's not
decide on a solution and then look for
reasons to back up that solution